great now that we've got our data loaded
we're at the point where we can start
playing some sounds let's take a look at
our skeleton code for this we have a
play sound method that takes a path to
the sound effect that you want to play
as well as an object containing all the
settings for our purposes let's say the
settings dictionary contains a boolean
looping for checking whether we want to
loop an effect and volume to set our
initial gain what we want you to do is
to create a source to play this sound
connect it to our main node and then
start playing it now there will be a
bunch of little things that you're going
to have to keep track of here is the
Sound Manager enabled is the sound
loaded or are we trying to play a null
sound don't worry we're going to be
giving you feedback as you submit your
code and which possibilities you haven't
taken into account yet